there's a basketball game being played
garyvee ladies gentlemen I'm getting
cracking McLibel rebrand if you will a
building directly to your brand of
whatever you're trying to accomplish
hawkers there's plenty of time [ __ ] I
was make Monday morning my [ __ ] there's
a basketball game being played and it's
a five on three game the five players on
our side or mean you other Tyler d-roc
and Andy K well stay with me me and Andy
can play a little bit the other three
the people were competing are LeBron
Kevin Durant and Carmelo to a game of
fifty full court what do you think the
score of that game would be okay very
good
there are way too many [ __ ] people at
Vayner and way too many people out there
in the world that think you solve things
and win by throwing people at that this
is a talent game
you don't need six more people on your
[ __ ] team to get the work done
you need to have better [ __ ] players
talent is part of the equation
everybody wants to put more people on
our team have a [ __ ] stepping up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]